[Music]  all i ever wanted in this world  is carnage  lady here  we should be out there snacking on bad  guys  i am a predator  i need to be free you have got to get  control of your aggression  but we will get hauled off into area 51.  live in my body you live by my walls  i'm sorry i don't know what came over me  please let me fix it  again  you are a loser  eddie brock i want to give you my story  people love serial killers  jesus why me  what's mine  it's yours and what's yours  is mine  i have tasted blood before and that is  not it  all i ever wanted in this world  is carnage  i'm not a crazy man  you feel like home to me  like family  oh wow you could just say i'm happy for  you that was going to be us hey i'm  happy for you  no  god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing  some serious couples  [Music]  you